good afternoon everybody welcome to the
first readout of the college for the
current academic year 2018 2019 I'm
delighted to welcome once again
Commissioner Vera yoga who will brief
you on the on the main dish of today's
menu before that let me brief you on a
number of horizontal files discussed by
the college firstly as a follow-up of
the college seminar last week the
president and his commissioners
discussed once again the main messages
for his State of the Union address as
you know this annual address on the 12th
of September we'll just as is the case
every year be accompanied by a series of
proposals which was well discussed once
more by the college and which will be
presented to you were going through a
fine tuning process as of next Wednesday
the college alsophila disease Yoda has
this rail initiative situation open
until a matter of a large de la cara de
novella hear set initiative up el árbol
illumine LaMontagne encourages any
motivational para que la comisión de la
comisión de resist reset initiative
nicola recive ability to dictate a
proposition la commission not personal
is a substance set initiative and
finally following the retirement of our
Director General in DG Sante mr. Xavier
Pratt's mone at the end of September
after a long distinguished career in the
Commission the college decided today to
appoint mrs. Ann Bush as his successor
director general de santé Madame
Buescher had a nationality Frances
reactor al Maleh president the committee
to examine la regla mantel show de la
commission
many de Servian depend on caleche active
market rebel adoption the priestess
anchor proposition legislative program
secretarial donor context de cárdenas
April annual proportion period nine
communicate the crest at about
disposition Donwell and curve in the
occasional farmer a la camisa Jonker and
now before passing the word to
Commissioner yerevan the data flows
adequacy between you and Japan I would
like to use this occasion to offer on
behalf of the college our condolences to
the Japanese people
authorities families and friends of
those who have lost their loved ones or
have been affected by the typhoon and
subsequent loss slide landslides and
floods we in the Commission reiterate
our solidarity with Japan and we stand
ready to provide assistance as
commissioner still aeneas already stated
publicly with this commissioner over to
you on the you Japan decision thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen I also
want to welcome you at today's press
conference I'm happy to see you after
summer in this unusual space of course
first of all I want to join the words of
condolence so and my thoughts are with
the families and the people affected in
Japan by the typhoon and indeed my dish
which I served today to my colleagues
and the president at the college has
Japanese tastes because I wanted to
update the caleche and seek the
endorsement to launch the process of
adoption of the e use decision to
recognize Japan as an adequate country
when it comes to protection of personal
data and thus along for personal data to
flow freely
a little bit of the historical context
if you remember in summer 2017 president
Luca and Prime Minister Abe a decided to
accompany the economic partnership
agreement with mutually ad across a
decision during this year's summit
we had the pleasure to announce that we
have successful
concluded negotiations once adopted this
mutual adequacy findings will create the
biggest area of free and safe flow of
data ever created it's very logical and
even necessary to accompany the
successful trade agreement
with the proper arrangement concerning
the protection of privacy that's why we
invested a lot in our negotiations first
of all we had to check if we are as I
sometimes say on the same planet with
Japan without Japan also recognize this
protection of privacy as the
constitutionally guaranteed fundamental
right and this is the case we were
comparing our GDP our with the Japanese
law Japanese law on data protection has
been amended last year and it's very
similar to what we have guaranteed for
the EU citizens in GDP are the
negotiations wasn't were not very easy
because Japanese system is different
from the European one there is a
different legal culture so we had a very
long talk about how other rights will be
enforced on Japanese side and after all
we came to a very good agreement and I I
am pretty much convinced that we are now
offering very high standard of
protection of privacy for Europeans one
figure there are 74,000 European
companies especially the smaller ones
which export data to Japan so for them
this decision will bring very good
portion of legal certainty and it will
enable them to do the business easier so
I submit it or I I asked for the
decision today the caleche decided that
can go on in the procedure of committee
ology so after this we will ask for the
opinion the European Data Protection
Board and data protection authorities we
will ask the Member States for
endorsement and we will inform the
European Parliament so the whole
procedure should end up I hope and I
believe strongly successfully at the end
of this year as you know this japanese
stocks and mutual request recognition
falls under the wider framework of the
European strategy for data protection in
Global's global scope as you know we
have the principle that the rights
travel mr. data of Europeans wherever
the data are exported so there are
countries where we have we have the
adequacy finding as now we seek for in
case of Japan and the the other
countries while we already started the
negotiations our sauce Korea we are
going to start negotiations with some
Latin American countries especially
Brazil and as and we are very happy that
also in India now they speak about
Indian gdpr which is one of the pieces
of evidence that gdpr has the global
impact and that in fact we are exporting
global standard for the protection of
private data ladies and gentlemen I am
available for your questions maybe you
want to ask also about other other
adequacy findings especially the privacy
shield which is a an agreement the
arrangement we recited for the data
flows to United States we are now
heading the second annual report
secretary will Barroso will come to
Brussels in October we have several very
tough conditions towards the American
site and the American partners are aware
requirements and I will try hard to have
the second report done in autumn and
continue the privacy shield as the
system which enables a huge transfers of
data from Europe to United States but I
cannot predict anything I said already
before that if our requirements are not
met on the American side we could take
an action but I don't want to predict
any any results yet thank you
Thank You commissioner let's now switch
to your questions keeping in mind that
we also have a technical briefing
following this midday readout with
experts on the subject so yes please hi
consumers from Politico I wanted to ask
about privacy shield there's been a
letter to the Parliament president from
the US government which wasn't very
recently I wanted to ask if you've
looked at that and if that provides any
any clarity as to your preparations for
it for the review and then secondly I
know there are some specific questions
one of them is appointing an ombudsman
ahead of the review I wanted to ask if
you've had any updates or what your
expectations are whether this will
actually be well this person will
actually be appointed ahead of the
review thank you for privacy shield I
must say that we needed some time to
explain the new administration in the
United States how important it is and of
course especially lburrows recognizes
the importance for the American business
so I rely on him and his pressure that
we will achieve what we want there is a
series of things which we want we are
very much in one line with data
protection authorities and European
Parliament because we want to improve
the system we want to have sustainable
well working system which will be under
the precise and prudent control from the
side of the American
authorities which have committed
themselves to do that we especially are
now monitoring what's happening around
the office of the ombudsman this office
and this concrete person plays very
important role in the whole system you
know that we wanted to have the
independent body in the United States
where the Europeans can watch their
complaints in case of suspicion that
their data have been abused on American
territory so now we recently received
the information that there will be
another acting on words person mr. sink
and soon we will see the sustainable
solution I hope which we recover very
strongly and it should be the fully
fledged appointed Ombudsperson who
should be the undersecretary these
assurances are also contained in the
letter which we received yesterday and
it's a letter from the office of mr.
Pompeo and we hope that those things
will be moving quickly in the right
direction also what I see in the United
States there is stronger pressure from
the society itself especially after the
case of Cambridge and analytical and the
revelations of the massive data abuse
and also the connection of this data
abuse with the elections I see that
there is the pressure that the United
States should have stricter law which
will guarantee the protection of private
data of American people so we hope that
also in the field of legislation the you
know the United States will be moving in
the right direction so these are
positive things but still of course now
in autumn 2018 we need to see all the
arrangements done on the American side
so that we can responsibly say that
privacy shield is the reliable system
which current is the protection of
private data of Europeans in United
States Perry Commissioner Patti Smith
Irish times a different topic and I
think it's still your brief but I've
heard suggestions that the Commission is
going to propose regulations to require
social media companies to take down
material from from websites in a speedy
time and make it mandatory rather than
the the voluntary system which is
operating at the moment can you confirm
that and can you tell me where
legislation is at the moment yes this is
the result of very intensive discussions
we had in Commission because everything
we can do visibly platforms and Internet
it's very sensitive because we sat one
principle we must not allow any kind of
censorship and in the EU however on the
platforms and an Internet we see that
some information and some content can
endanger security of Europeans so we are
looking into this from the point of view
of the of how the content can be
dangerous and here we differentiate two
things hate speech well we want to
continue the voluntary action you know
that we have the code of conduct now we
we have the biggest players on board and
they are deleting hate speech which is
prohibited by all the criminal laws in
all the Member States there is it is
still voluntary action so there is no
legal liability imposed on them but what
you indicated it concerns terrorist
content well we came to a conclusion
that it is too serious threat and risk
for European people that we should have
absolute certainty that all the
platforms and all the IT provider
will delete the terrorists content and
will cooperate with law enforcement
bodies in all the Member States so we
want to come with the proposal that it
will be the obligation to delete such
content after notification and it is the
proposal which will come soon
now in September so you will know all
the details later on I fully agree that
we in in terrorism and security securing
safety for Europeans we simply cannot
rely anymore on voluntary action of the
EIT providers which has one more
downside that we do not cover all range
of all the IT providers only those who
applied for the account code of conduct
so yes this is now in the final stage
that's why it's better to have
commissioners in the press room I would
have said stay tuned the Commission has
said much more going back to data
protection
it's about GDP are there were several
member states which didn't didn't sorry
the GDP are at the moment of 25 of May I
wanted to know if there is some progress
in this and in particularly if Italy has
approved the GDP are and in case not
given the fact that we are approaching
two European elections aren't you
worried that member states where GDP are
is not applied it's the citizens will be
less protected in case of micro
targeting political campaigns given the
fact that you have many parties
political parties like Logano and
movement to Cinque cell in Italy that
really communicate through social media
thank you thank you very much
first on Italy as maybe you remember
around the date of the application of of
GDP are I said that there are several
states which didn't manage to adopt a
national laws GDP are is the regulation
but we expected all the member states to
adopt their legislation related to GDP
are because we left some space for
further national specificity our state
specificities and Italy belong to those
states which were slow so we received
the proposal or order the text of the
Italian law this week so we are going to
analyze it and in case there are some
gaps or some things which go beyond GPR
or which are not compliant with GDP are
we will come back to Italian authorities
but overall it is a good news that Italy
finally has the law on the second thing
you know that I was very concerned after
Cambridge analytical about the new
situation about the evidence that
micro-targeting an abuse of private data
can be efficiently used in political
campaigning and I sat in Spain that this
is something we do not want in Europe we
don't want in Europe to have easy to
manipulate or easily manipulatable crowd
we want free citizens to have their free
choice in elections without being
manipulated and without being the
victims of abuse of their private data
so that's why
and I said in spring that commission
will respond to that so that's why we
will adopt the package next year next
week concerning the upcoming elections
it will be focused on European elections
but in fact it's applicable to all
elections in the Member States and we
will recommend the Member States to
guarantee something which they should
guarantee anyway that strict gdpr rules
will be applied in the period before the
elections and in it concerns the Member
States role in it
the political parties role in it and
also of course at the citizens who
should maybe pay more attention to what
what's happening to them in principle
what we will want to do is that the
rules which apply in offline world
should be applied also for online space
because of a flying is over it's very
much heavily regulated
there are many strict rules regarding
political campaigns and we want more
transparency and better rules for online
especially in the sense that the citizen
should know when he reads the political
advertisement I think that this is
essential thing so it will come next
next week and I will share more
information with you next week yes
please at the back efficiency from
Polish press agency a different topic
budget Commissioner general articles and
Tuesday that the European project is in
a mortal danger and from opponents
inside and outside the EU and this is
called some with within Europe one to
weaken it or even destroy it Poland
Hungary Romania the government of Italy
so I would like to know whether you
agree with this opinion whether we share
this opinion whether this is a like
official position of the European
Commission thank you very much I would
not speak about a mortal danger
I think intro didn't have a good day
when he
this because it is too dark picture but
it's absolutely true that Europe is
challenged there are so many challenges
from outside but also a lot of difficult
things which we see and dangerous
developments which we see inside Europe
in in some Member States so I am life
optimist I believe that this pressure
will make Europe stronger we will have
to be more resilient and we will have to
be more United
so I read an opinion of one Wiseman who
said that
prax it might drink but cohesion effect
than all the cohesion funds it is not my
opinion I very much his team but the
cohesion funds are doing in Europe but
to some extent this is true that if when
you are under pressure and when you have
the strong will to survive it was a wife
and you will get stronger a question
related to Google according to media
reporter in the summer Google is
tracking people with its devices even
when
there they have hoped out of being
tracked are you aware of this practice
are you asking information to Google and
would it be in breach of the gdpr thank
you I am absolutely convinced that the
enforcers who work in the EU and these
are the data protection authorities are
following this and many other cases
which show that there is still the
danger that some companies and some some
entities do not comply with the gdpr
rules so I cannot tell you if Google is
being investigated but I would guess
that the Data Protection pay attention
to this and similar cases anything else
for the Commissioner before we switch to
technical briefing I don't see anything
else so Christian is now taking over
with the experts and I'll see you
tomorrow Thank You commissioner thank
you